- What I'd like to do in
this video is start exploring
how we can model things with
the differential equations.
And in this video in particular,
we will explore modeling population.
Modeling population.
We're actually going to
go into some depth on
this eventually, but here we're going
to start with simpler models.
And we'll see, we will stumble on using
the logic of differential equations.
Things that you might have seen
in your algebra or your precalculus class.
So, in some level, what
we're going to do here
is going to be review, but
we're going to get there
using the power of modeling
with differential equations.
So let's just define some variables.
Let's say that P is
equal to our population.
And let's say that t
is, let's say that t is
equal to the time that has passed in days.
In days, it could have
been years or months.
But let's say we're
doing the population of
insects that reproduce quite quickly.
So days seem like a nice
time span to care about.
Now, what would be a reasonable model?
Well, we could say that
the rate of change,
the rate of change of our
population, with respect to time,
with respect to time is, well,
a reasonable thing to say
is that it's going to be proportional
to the actual population,
the actual population.
Why is that reasonable?
Well, the larger the population,
the larger the rate at any given time.
If you have a thousand people, the rate
at which they're reproducing
is going to be more,
or a thousand insects is
going to be more insects
per second, per day or per year
than if you only have 10 insects.
So it makes sense that the rate of growth
of your population, with respect to time,
is going to be proportional
to your population.
And so, you know, sometimes you think of
differential equations as
these daunting complex things,
but notice we've just been able to express
a reasonably not so complicated idea.
The rate of change of population is going
to be proportional to the population.
And now, once we've expressed
that, we can actually
try to solve this differential equation.
Find a general solution, and
then we can try to put some
initial conditions on there or
some states of the population
that we know to actually
solve for the constants
to find a particular solution.
So how do we do that?
And I encourage you to
pause the video at any time
and see if you can solve
this differential equation.
So assuming you, at least,
maybe have had an attempt at it,
and you might immediately recognize that
this is a separable differential equation.
And in separable differential equations,
we want one variable and
all the differentials
involving that variable on one
side, and the other variable
and all the differentials involving
the other variable on the other side,
and then we can integrate both sides.
And once again, dP, the
derivative of P with respect to t,
this isn't quite a fraction.
This is the limit as our change
in P over change in time.
This is our instantaneous
change, but for the sake of
separable differential equations
or differential equations
in general, you can treat,
you can treat these, this
derivative in Leibniz notations
like fractions, and you can
treat these differentials
like quantities because we
will eventually integrate them.
So let's do that.
So, we want to put all
the Ps and dPs on one side
and all the, all the things that involve t
or that I guess don't
involve P on the other side.
So, we could divide both sides by P.
We could divide both sides
by P, and so we'll have
one over P, and you have one over P
here and then those will cancel,
and then you can multiply
both sides times dt.
We could multiply both sides times dt.
Once again, treating the
differential like a quantity
which isn't, it really isn't a quantity.
You really have to view this as a limit of
change in P over change in time.
The limit as we get smaller and smaller
and smaller changes in time.
But for, once again, for the sake of this
we can do this, and when we do that
we would be left with one over P dP
is equal to, is equal to
k dt, is equal to k dt.
Now we can integrate,
integrate both sides.
Because this was a separable
differential equation,
we were able to completely
separate the Ps and dPs from
the things involving ts or, I guess,
the things that aren't
involving Ps, and then
if we integrate this side,
we would get the natural log,
the natural log of the absolute
value of our population,
and we could say plus
some constant if we want
but we're going to get a
constant on this side as well
so we could just say that's
going to be equal to,
that's going to be equal to
k, it's going to be equal to
k times t, k times t plus some constant.
Plus some constant.
I'll just call that C one, and once again
I could've put a plus C
two here, but I could've
then subtracted the
constant from both sides
and I would just get the
constant on the right hand side.
Now, how can I solve for P?
Well, the natural log of
the absolute value of P
is equal to this thing right over here.
That means that's the same thing.
That means that the absolute value of P,
that means that the absolute value of P
is equal to e to all this business,
e to the, e to the, let
me do in the same colors,
kt, kt plus,
plus C one, plus C one.
Now this right over
here is the same thing.
Just using our exponent
properties, this is the same thing
as e to the kt,
e to the k times t
times e, times e to the C one,
e to the C one.
Now this is just e to some constant,
so we could just call this,
let's just call that the constant C.
So this is all simplified to C e,
C e to the kt,
to the kt.
And if we assume our
population at any given time
is positive then we could get rid of
this absolute value sign, and
we have a general solution
to this, frankly, fairly
general differential equation.
We just said proportional.
We haven't given what the
proportionality constant is,
but we could say, if we
assume, positive population
that the population is
going to be equal to
some constant C times e to the kt power.
To the kt power, and the
reason why I said that
you've seen this before is this
is just an exponential function,
and it's very likely that
in algebra or in precalculus class
you have modeled things
with exponential functions,
and my guess is that
you've modeled things,
modeled things like population.
The reason why this is interesting is
you now see where this is coming from.
The underlying logic that's just driven
by the actual differential equation.
The rate of change, with respect
to time, of the population.
Well, maybe it's just
proportional to population.
So I'll leave you there,
and in the next video
we'll do what you probably
did in the 10th or 11th grade
or maybe later in your
life, it doesn't matter when
you did it, where we actually look at some
initial conditions to find
a particular solution.